bobo alors stéphane tient la vidéo mais
non mais non mais non
oh mais non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis ravi de vous retrouver
une nouvelle fois comme toujours pour
une nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui on va
faire un tuto de la mort qui tue en mode
vulcanien à base de stéphane couchoux et
si vous êtes nouveau sur cette chaîne
ici on parle de création de vidéos de
montage de captation donc si c'est
quelque chose qui vous plaît n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner y aura sûrement des
choses qui vont vous plaire
dans les vidéos à venir et dans les
vidéos passé alors je sais pas si vous
avez vu la dernière vidéo de stéphane
couchoux je mets le lien dans la
description de la vidéo et de sa chaîne
si vous n'êtes pas abonné il faut vous
abonner à stéphane couchoux c'est juste
un tueur cette vidéo c'était une vidéo
de drones fpv qui était vraiment
hallucinante avec des plans et des
screens de ouf
vraiment mais moi ce qui m'a fait tiquer
c'est un petit effet quitté calais un
petit peu partout dans la vidéo et qui
était vraiment vraiment vraiment cool
cet effet il donnait ça on a les
fameuses bandes noires qui donne le
ratio de 35 et par moments on a les
objets ou les éléments du décor qui
viennent passer par dessus les bandes
noires pour donner un effet immersif et
pour donner presque un effet un peu 3d
parallaxe qui est vachement sympa et
quand j'ai vu ça je me suis dit mais
c'est tout simple à faire c'est rien du
tout mais en même temps c'est hyper
créatif et c'est hyper adapté à la vidéo
de drones effet vie que steph assorti au
passage je remercie stéphane n'est pas
autorisée à utiliser des extraits de ces
vidéos pour illustrer le tuto donc rien
de compliqué dans cet été vous allez
voir je vais vous montrer comment on
fait c'est vraiment très très simple
mais ça a été hyper malin de la part de
stéphane puisque le drone fpv par
définition c'est de la vue plus ou moins
la première personne en drones donc
c'est déjà quelque chose d' immersif et
le fait de rajouter cet effet par
moments sur certains éléments ça donne
le petit plus qui fait que la vidéo sort
un petit peu du lot parce que des vidéos
de drones fpv on en voit de plus en plus
et là ça lui permet vraiment d'avoir un
quelque chose d'un petit peu différente
et en plus des skills de ouf et de la
maîtrise du trône fpv quand même faut
dire ce qui est d'ailleurs les bandes
noires on avait fait une vidéo avec ar
disque avec le lien qui s'affiche
quelque part en haut de votre écran et
dans la description
mais trêve de blabla je vous montre tout
de suite comment je pense que steve a
fait son effet dans final cut mais vous
allez voir rester pendant tôt parce
qu'il veut voir des trucs qui vont
s'afficher pour vous montrer comment on
fait aussi dans première parce que
très compliqué au final alors j'ai placé
dans ma timeline ici un plan et oui
voilà un petit bonhomme de neige
bah oui moi j'ai pas les skills de stef
en drones fpv alors je fais avec ce que
j'ai puis les minions mon petit bonhomme
de neige et je vais ajouter ici un cal
clutterbuck ce jeu vous met un lien dans
la description de pour le télécharger
voilà hop on va l'ajuster et voilà on
and on bandeaux noirs ici et c'est super
facile à trouver un mot sur google on en
trouve en version 4 k fins et voilà
c'est rien du tout et puis on avait vu
comment on faisait ça dans la vidéo avec
ar disque ensuite tout ce que je vais
faire c'est aller chercher les faits
masque de tracé qui se trouve ici et
l'appliquer sur le lecteur vote et vous
pouvez en profiter pour aller voir la
vidéo qui s'affiche en ce moment sur
votre écran qui permet de faire des
transitions avec cet effet là qui est
vraiment cool aussi des transitions à
base de masques de tracé alors on va
aller sélectionner notre plan et puis
commencer à placer les points autour du
bonhomme et par dessus les bandes noires
le bonhomme ou notre sujet en voilà on
va aller cliquer sur inverser le plan
sinon c'est pas forcément on va inverser
la mauvaise chose et on va aller
s'assurer que chaque angle chaque point
ici et bien aligné avec notre sujet
alors on va pouvoir aussi rajouter des
points double cliquant sur la ligne
puisque forcément avec 4 points au
départ on va être un peu limite et on va
aller s'assurer qu'on peut bien tout
recouvrir
ensuite on va aller au niveau de
transformation et de points de contrôle
pour activer et qui frame de façon à ce
que chaque
image et un masque différents qui évolue
puis je vais pouvoir avancer d'image en
image grâce aux flèches avant et arrière
est modifiée à chaque fois un tout petit
peu mon masque pour qu'ils restent bien
collé à l'élément que je veux détaché à
l'élément que je veux faire passer par
dessus les bandes noires et ensuite il
n'y a plus qu'à je vous accélère le tour
alors petite astuce parce que des fois
les angles c'est pas fou fou si vous
cliquez sur un des points de contrôle
avec le bouton commandes affichées vous
allez pouvoir arrondir les angles si je
puis dire et permettent de quelque chose
d'un peu plus doux d'un petit peu moins
anguleux et ça va vous permettre de
coller encore mieux au sujet est
l'élément que vous voulez masqué ou
faire apparaître
enfin pour fignoler on va pouvoir jouer
sur l'atténuation et l'adoucissement 1
comme ici avec les curseurs pour pouvoir
un petit peu vérifier que tout colle
bien et adoucir un petit peu les bords
pour que ce soit pas trop abrupte et
puis après il reste plus qu'à finir les
un petit peu les détails à arrondir
certains angles à vérifier que tout est
bien calé et bien correct ça prend du
temps mais au final le rendu il est
vraiment bluffant et voilà c'était tout
simple le rendu il est bluffant
franchement c'est c'est une super idée
qu'a eue steph' là attention quand même
les effets c'est comme tout il faut pas
en abuser c'est comme les transitions
pour mettre ça quand ça a du sens et
quand ça sert un petit peu votre vidéo
donc pas en mettre partout mais c'est
bien d'avoir ça dans votre arsenal quand
même au cas où vous auriez besoin de
vous en servir ça peut rendre un effet
assez simple et c'est pas uniquement
destiné aux drones à ferrer 11 avez vu
on peut le faire sur plein de choses
donc voilà les amis si cette vidéo vous
a plus pensé c'est hyper important à
mettre le traditionnel coup de blaster
et pv ou paf verrez sur le pouce en
l'air qui se situe juste en dessous de
cette vidéo vous pouvez également vous
abonner penser à la cloche ça aussi
c'est important pour être notifiées pour
me dire aussi dans les commentaires si à
d'autres effets que vous voudriez qu'on
traite et puis moi je vous dis les amis
comme d'habitude rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
alors steve si tu regarde cette vidéo
moi j'ai une très très humble requête à
te faire j'ai les images sont ouvre dans
paradoxe et tout ça moi je suis aussi
fan du super scénario pour paradex 3
parce que je sais que tu penses à
parader kz3 tu nous fais un scénario de
ouf avec les images de ouf
et là ça va être mais le paradis quoi le
paradis sur terre le paradoxe voilà
et voilà mais humblement parce que
chapeau l'artiste
bien joué vraiment balèze